>>> A GROWING MBER OF STAT
ARE PLANNG TO END THEIR INDOOR
MASK MANDATES AS THE RATES DROP
SIGNIFICANTLY.
THE CDC IS PLANNING TO DROP ITS
GUIDANCE FOR ALL AMERICANS.
THEY SAY PEOPLE SHOULD CONTINUE
WEARING MASKS IN HIGH AREAS OF
TRANSMISSION.
THAT'S ABOUT 99% OF THE
COUNTIES.
>> ONLY ABOUT 27% OF THE BOOST
ED POPULATION HAD RECEIVED THE
BOOSTER.
>> Reporter: FROM COAST TO COAST
GOVERNORS ARE ROLLING BACK THEIR
MASK MANDATE.
ACCORDING TO ANALYSIS, ONLY
THESE SIX STATES INCLUDING
PUERTO RICO AND WASHINGTON, D.C.
HAVE THESE IN PLACE.
THAT LEAVES WASHINGTON, PUERTO
RICO, AND WASHINGTON, D.C. WITH
NO PLANS ON WHEN THEY'LL END
THEIR MASK MANDATE.
SCHOOL CLASSROOMS HAVE MOVED
TOWARD ENDING MASK MANDATES OR
EXPECT TO DO SO BY THE END OF
MARCH.
HOWEVER, LOCAL GOVERNMENTS AND
SCHOOL DISTRICTS ARE STILL FREE
TO MAKE MASKS A MUST EVEN AFTER
MANDATES ARE LIFTED.
>> THIS IS THEIR RIGHT.
SO WHAT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE IS
TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
INDIVIDUALS TO PROTECT
THEMSELVES.
AND SO WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
THAT MEANS BASICALLY MAKING A
HIGH-QUALITY MASK LIKE THE N95
MASK AS AVAILABLE AS TOILET
PAPER AND SOAP.
>> Reporter: WHEN MAKING THEIR
DECISION, THEY'RE LOOKING AT
HOSPITALIZATION NUMBERS.
SOME WORRY THAT THEY COULD BE
FALLING BEHIND.
>> RIGHT NOW WE'VE GOT THE STATE
SAYING ONE THING AND THE CDC
SAYING THEY'RE LOOKING AT THIS
AGAIN, AND THAT'S JUST NOT
ENOUGH.
>> Reporter: THE DOCTOR URGING
THE CDC TO ISSUE MASKING
GUIDANCE.
>> MY PATIENTS EVERY DAME COME
TO ME AND SAY, WELL, I'M HEARING
THIS AND I'M HEARING THIS FROM A
LOCAL TOWN AGENCY, AND I DON'T
KNOW WHAT TO DO.
IT'S DAMAGING TO THE TRUST AND
PSYCHE.
>> Reporter: ALSO LOSING THE
MASKS, AMAZON.
THEY ANNOUNCED FULLY VACCINATED,
WEERS CAN GO MASKLESS.
THE NEW POLICY DOES NOT APPLY TO
TON VACCINATED OR THOSE WORKING
IN THE FEW STATES WHERE MASKING
INDOORS REMAINS IN PLACE, FOR
NOW.
POLO SANDOVAL, CNN, NEW YORK.
>>> JOINING ME NOW TO TALK ABOUT
THIS IS A PEDIATRIC SURGEON AT
COLUMBIA UNIVERSITY CENTER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR JOINING
US.
I THINK POLO'S PIECE REALLY GETS
TO THIS.
WE'VE BEEN DEALING WITH IT.
ACROSS THE COUNTRY YOU HAVE
LOCAL MASK MANDATES THAT ARE
GOING AWAY.
THE MANDATES HAVEN'T CHANGED.
WHAT ADVICE WOULD YOU GIVE
SOMEONE IN AN AREA WITH HIGH
RATE OF TRANSMISSION BUT NO
MANDATE ON MASKING?
>> NO MATTER WHAT I THINK,
RIGHT, THIS IS HAPPENING, AND
YOU HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
RIGHT THERE BY TALKING ABOUT
WHAT THE LOCAL TRANSMISSION RATE
IS.
THAT'S THE KEY.
PEOPLE NEED TO REALLY LOOK AT
WHAT THEIR LOCAL RATES OF
INFECTION ARE, WHAT THEIR LOCAL
RATES OF POSITIVE TESTS ARE IN
COMBINATION WITH THE VACCINATION
RATES.
IT IS DIFFERENT FOR SOMETHING
LIVING IN PLAEM.
RATES BARELY HOVERING AT 60%.
OTHER STATES LIKE NEW YORK AND
NNCH
NEW JERSEY ARE APPROACHING 95%.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO PAY ATTENTION
TO PAY ATTENTION TO VACCINATED
AROUND YOUR KIDS, ASKING KIDS TO
MASK IF THEY'RE INDOORS IN
CLASSROOMS, AND BE AWARE OF
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH INFECTION
RATES AROUND YOU, AND PUT IN
PLACE ALL OF THOSE PROTECTIVE
MEASURES IF THE INFECTION RATES
ARE HIGH.
IF IT'S LOWER, IT'S NOT
UNREASONABLE TO MOVE TOWARD
LOOSENING SOME OF THESE
RESTRICTIONS BECAUSE WE HAVE TO
START LIVING IN A WORLD WHERE WE
RAMP UP PROTECTIONS WHEN WE NEED
THEM AND WE HAVE AN OFF-RAMP
WHEN CASES ARE LOWER.
>> THIS ISN'T A MONOLITHIC
MOMENT.
COMMUNITIES ARE DIFFERENT,
HOLIDAYS ARE DIFFERENT, STATES
ARE DIFFERENT.
BUT IT'S ALSO A MOMENT WHERE THE
POPULATION IS READY TO MOVE ON.
PEOPLE ARE TIRED OF EVERYTHING
DESPITE THE FACT THAT MORE THAN
2,000 PEOPLE ARE DIEING ON A
DAILY BASIS AT THIS POINT, BUT
IT GETS TO THE POLITICAL/EXHAUST
PLAN AT THIS TIME WHERE IT'S
RESPONSE TOBL SHIFT IT WHERE
PEOPLE MAY BE MORE BROADLY.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND PEOPLE NEED TO PLAN FOR THE
NEXT STEP.
I THINK A HUGE PART OF THE ISSUE
IS NOT HAVING A NEXT STEP, AND I
THINK ACROSS THE COUNTRY, CASE
RATES ARE STILL HIGH ENOUGH.
POSITIVITY RATES EVEN IN THE
BEST AREAS STILL ARE ABOVE 5%.
WE REALLY WANT THEM LOWER THAN
5% TO FEEL COMFORTABLE, BUT
WITHIN THE NEXT COUPLE OF WEEKS,
YOU KNOW, CASE NUMBERS HAVE BEEN
DROPPING SO PRECIPITOUSLY.
BY THE END OF THE MONTH, A LOT
OF PLACES WILL BE VERY READY TO
HAVE MUCH MORE LIBERAL FREEDOM
AND NOT MASKING AND REALLY
SEEING SOME OF THESE
PROTECTIONS.
SO THE CDC REALLY DOES NEED TO
GIVE THAT NEXT STEP TO PEOPLE SO
THEY UNDERSTAND WHAT THEY SHOULD
BE LOOKING FOR, WHAT IS THE CDC
RECOMMENDING PEOPLE PAY
ATTENTION TO, AND WHEN MIGHT WE
MOVE FORTH FROM THIS.
WE'VE GOT TO HAVE A NEXT STEP.
WE'VE GOT TO BE GETTING THERE
BECAUSE CASE RATES ARE DROPPING
SO, SO MUCH.
PEOPLE ARE LOOKING TO THE CDC AS
THEY HAVE BEEN TOWARD PROVIDING
THE NEXT STEP.
IF THEY DON'T, THEY SHOULD LOOK
TO THEIR LOCAL AND REGIONAL
GOVERNMENT.
>> WHEN IT COMES TO KIDS --
LOOK, I'VE GOT THREE YOUNG KIDS,
I LIVE IN A PERPETUAL STATE OF
CONFUSION AND READING GUIDELINES
I GENERALLY DON'T UNDERSTAND.
YOU TALK ABOUT THE NEXT STEP.
WHAT'S YOUR PLAN WITH REGARD TO
KIDS, CLASSROOMS, MASKS, AND
WHAT SHOULD HAPPEN?
>> AS YOU SAY, IT SHOULD DEPEND
ON YOUR AREA.
BUT IF YOU'RE IN AN AREA THAT IS
RELATIVELY WELL PROTECTED, YOUR
DISTRICT OR YOUR SCHOOL HAS A
REASONABLE VACCINATION RATE,
YOUR CASE RATES ARE COMING DOWN,
THEN, YES, DISTRICTS, I THINK,
CAN MOVE FORWARD WITH LIFTING
MASK MANDATES AND GOING WITHOUT
IN THE COMING WEEKS.
I STRONGLY URGE PARENTS,
FAMILIES WHO ARE IN AREAS OF
HIGH CASE NUMBERS WHO HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THEIR ELIGIBLE KIDS
VACCINATED TO GO AHEAD AND GET
THEM VACCINATED.
THAT IS ANOTHER REALLY IMPORTANT
STEP FOR FAMILIES TO TAKE, TO
FEEL COMFORTABLE RELEASING THESE
MASK MANDATES, TO GIVE KIDS MORE
FREEDOMS.
OUR 5- TO 11-YEAR-OLDS ARE STILL
ONLY AT 23% IN TERMS OF THE
VACCINATION RATE ACROSS THE
COUNTRY.
AND 12 TO 17-YEAR-OLDS ARE 50%
VACCINATED.
WE HAVE A LOT OF ROOM TOWARD
WORKING TO GET THEM VACCINATED.
>> THE TOOLS EXIST.
IF THERE'S ONE THING SO CL